what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and i know everybody is
wondering where the heck is that thor
love and thunder first teaser trailer
it's about to break the record for
having the least amount of days between
the very first teaser trailer's release
and the actual movies release in the
theaters which is pretty sad because
this is a very highly anticipated teaser
trailer definitely one of the more
anticipated marvel trailers and
unfortunately it doesn't look like it's
going to be coming anytime soon at least
not this week and i'll explain why and
if you love marvel and love to stay up
to date be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you don't miss
out on any of the latest news now i know
fans were pretty disappointed last night
with the oscars some rumors went around
this week that the trailer could drop
during the oscars during a commercial
because the oscars air on a channel that
disney owns but aside from will smith
slapping chris rock it was pretty
uneventful oh wow
wow
will smith
but now people are starting to ask well
is the trailer at least close to coming
because like i said in the beginning
thor love and thunder is about to beat
the incredible hulk's record for the
least amount of days between the release
of a trailer and the release of a film
now we thought we waited a really long
time for the spider-man no way home
first teaser trailer and we did but this
has already beat that record we've
officially waited longer for the thor
love and thunder trailer than we have
for spider-man no way home there was 116
days between the first teaser trailer
for no way home and the release of the
official movie thor love and thunder has
officially beaten that record because as
of right now we are 102 days away from
thor love and thunder's july 8th release
date now the incredible hulk has the
record of 93 days between the first
teaser trailer and the official release
date so thor love and thunder is
creeping up and it looks like it's not
going to come this week this week is the
official release of the first episode of
moon night so marvel most likely is not
going to drop it this week because they
don't want that to overshadow moon night
in any way they want all of the buzz
this week to focus on moon night so
we're at least a week away but we do
know that thor love and thunder has
recently undergone some reshoots and we
don't know if that's still happening
right now of course marvel loves to keep
some things secret but we know that very
recently reshoots happened now this
could definitely affect a trailer
especially if it's a very specific scene
that they want to show in the teaser
they obviously can't show the teaser
until they get that scene done so if we
are waiting on some reshoots it might be
a little bit until we get that trailer
and i just really hope that thor love
and thunder doesn't get delayed because
this is pretty late in the game to be
doing reshoots however there is still
plenty of time until the actual release
date and there is some good news in
regards to the trailer last week we got
some thor love and thunder official toy
sets released which means promotion for
the film has begun this is good news
because typically promotion starts right
before we get the first teaser so it
looks like marvel studios has every
intention on releasing this relatively
soon and as long as one it doesn't
interfere with another marvel project
and two they have all of the footage
that they need we should get it
relatively soon perhaps in a couple of
weeks from now and of course as always
if i hear anything i'll be sure to do an
update on it but do you have a
prediction for when we are going to get
that trailer if you do let me know down
below and also don't forget about the
moon night watch parties watch parties
are coming back we'll be doing it
tuesday night well i guess wednesday
morning 12 30 a.m hope to see you there
don't forget to like the video and of
course subscribe if you want to stay up
to date on all the latest mcu news for
live updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof